welcome to part three of strike payments
with angular and firebase in the last
two episodes we integrated the stripe
check out and charge the card with
firebase cloud functions in this third
episode we're going to use that charge
to enable the user to purchase digital
content in our app in this example we
keep a balance on the user's account
which can be increased by making
payments or decreased by purchasing
content when a user has sufficient funds
on their account they can click a button
that will bring up a modal window to
confirm or cancel the purchase if they
click confirm their account balance is
automatically updated with the new
balance the database will be updated
with a purchases collection which tracks
the user ID and the item IDs that they
purchased the users current balance will
be tracked on their actual account with
a new property called balance which
takes a number let's start by updating
the cloud function we need it to update
both the charge as well as the users
balance in the same operation we want it
to be atomic meaning if the charge fails
the user balance update will fail also
and vice-versa the first step is to
create a balance variable defaults to
zero and then when we get the customer
record we'll update it with their
existing balance when we get the stripe
charge back we'll first check to make
sure it exists and we'll also check to
make sure that it's actually paid if
these conditions are met we create an
object where the key is a reference
point in the database and the value is
the data we want to update this allows
us to update multiple database locations
at the same time but be careful it
performs a set operation so make sure
you point to the very deepest node that
you want to update now we can use the
charge amount from stripe to increase
the users balance and then send these
updates together to the root of the
database back in the app we can see the
users balance is updated by the cloud
function when they make a payment now we
need to update the service to handle the
payment process in order to get the user
balance we first need the auth user ID
so we'll use the switch map operator on
the in Euler fire off observable we'll
move this out into its own function and
then subscribe to it and then
struktur the balance itself will be
emitted as an object so we just want to
map that object to its actual value so
we just get a number back in the
observable from there we need to
determine if the user has already
purchased a product which we can do by
seeing if that key exists under their
purchases in the database this will also
return an observable and we'll map it to
a boolean value to get the true false
value back instead of the entire object
itself and the last step is to create a
function that enables the user to
actually make the purchase it requires
the unique ID of the item being
purchased as well as the amount and it
records the time stamp from the firebase
server this will guarantee your time
stamps are consistent which would not be
the case if you just use the JavaScript
data object this function also needs to
make an atomic update to update the
balance as well as the purchase history
in the same operation so we'll create
another updates object and pass it the
corresponding data the user balance gets
decreased by the amount of the purchase
and the purchase history gets the
purchase object we can then pass these
updates to the root of the database and
call the update function now let's
create a new component called the Buy
Now component it's designed to be
reusable so we'll take the viable ID as
well as the amount from the parent
component the buyable ID just represents
any item that can be purchased we also
create a variable to toggle the
visibility of the modal during ng on an
it we define the variables for the user
balance observable and that has
purchased observable then we create an
event handler to change the visibility
of the modal and the last function we
need is for the user to actually confirm
the purchase so this will just run the
buy digital content function that we
defined in the service when the purchase
is complete we close the modal and you
could also consider adding a success
message or confirmation at this point
but before we get into the HTML we're
going to create a custom stripe pipe to
format currency amounts this
is strictly for the user and it will
turn the value into a string with the
proper decimal now striped amounts are
1/100 of the underlying currency so 500
and stripe equals five US dollars from a
parent component we passed the unique ID
as well as the price to the Buy Now
component in the component itself we add
the is active class when the show modal
variable is true this is specific to
Bulma CSS we can unwrap the balance
observable to see if the user has
sufficient funds on their account to
make the purchase if so we'll show them
that confirm or cancel buttons we can
also show the user what their current
balance is and what their balance will
look like after the purchase the confirm
button will actually make the purchase
and the cancel button will just toggle
the modal back to false if the user
doesn't have enough money we'll show
different modal content that says
insufficient funds with their current
balance the last step is to create a
button that will open the modal in the
first place if the users already
purchased the item then we'll go ahead
and just show button it says already
purchased it's disabled notice how we
always unwrap the observables in
parentheses using the async pipe and
then call any logic outside those
parentheses before we start using the
system let's also add some back-end data
security rules on firebase when a
purchase is made we want to make sure
that user ID always matches the current
auth user ID and we also want to prevent
purchasers from being updated or deleted
after they've been created so the data
exists then we won't allow any write
operations to take place now going back
to the app we can take a look and make
sure that everything is working as
expected I currently have five dollars
on my account which is insufficient to
buy this product so we'll add additional
credits through stripe which should
increase the account balance from $5 to
$25
and we'll see the account balance here
update asynchronously once it's done
processing then scribe and now we have
sufficient cleanse on the account so we
should be able to go ahead and buy the
product that pulls up the confirmation
screen
if we click confirm it should reduce the
balance by twenty dollars which it does
and now we're back at five dollars again
and we have access to the product that's
it for stripe payments if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
if you want a free copy of that book the
angularfire Bank Survival Guide consider
becoming a pro member or just 9 bucks a
month you'll get a free copy of that
book as well as access to our proton
slack or one on one project consulting
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]